THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING TO
THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU!
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
>> Larry: THAT WAS SUCH AN
AMAZING THING THAT HAPPENED.
WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST REACTION
WHEN YOU SAW THAT IN YOUR SON'S
TEXTBOOK?
>> WELL, I KIND OF CHUCKLED
BECAUSE OF HIS TEXT MESSAGE.
I KNEW HE WAS BEING SARCASTIC
WAS, "WE WAS REAL HARD WORKERS,
WEREN'T WE?"
I THOUGHT IT WAS EQUALLY
RIDICULOUS.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT.
>> Larry: IT'S JUST AMAZING TO
ME, IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE REPORTED
ON SOME STORIES.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S SOME SOFT
SELLING ON SOME OF THE BAD PARTS
OF AMERICAN HISTORY TO MAKE KIDS
FEEL BETTER?
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE?
>> I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT.
I BELIEVE WE WANT TO TELL THESE
STORIES CAN WE WANT TO SOFTEN
THEM.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE WANT TO
WRITE HISTORY WITH A PENCIL
INSTEAD OF A BLEEDING PEN.
AND YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: RIGHT.
BUT IT'S LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO
HURT THEIR FEELINGS IF WE TELL
THE TRUTH.
>> LIKE WE DON'T WANT TO TELL
THEM THEY WERE SLAVES AND WE
KIDNAPPED THEM.
YES, YOU DID.
>> Larry: IT MAKES US BETTER
TO KNOW THE TRUTH, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Larry: KNOWING THOSE TRUTHS
HELPS YOU MOVE PAST IT.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO SEE WHO WE WERE AS A COUNTRY
TO SEE WHERE WE CAME FROM, TO
SEE WE DIDN'T START OFF-- WE'RE
OBSESSED WITH THE IDEA OF
AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM, THAT
WE'RE PERFECT AND THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE HAVE SOME UGLINESS IN
OUR PAST, TOO, AND WE NEED TO
OWN IT.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: ABSOLUTELY.
SO TRUE.
AND ALL OF US WERE INVOLVED IN
THE PAST.
BUT ALL OF US ARE INVOLVED IN
MAKING A BETTER FUTURE, TOO.
HOW IMPORTANT DO YOU THINK IT IS
FOR PARENTS TO BE VIGILANT WITH
THEIR KIDS' EDUCATION AND THAT
TYPE OF THING?
>> OH, MY GOSH.
IT IS EVERYTHING.
EVERY PIECE OF PAPER THAT COMES
HOME.
EVERY ASSIGNMENT.
I MEAN, DIG THROUGH THAT
BACKPACK.
MAKE IT YOUR BUSINESS TO FIND
OUT WHAT THEY WERE TEACHING THEM
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: ABSOLUTELY.
AND TO McGRAW-HILL'S CREDIT,
THEY ARE GOING TO CHANGE THIS
AND WHAT ARE THEY, LIKE-- PUT
SOME STICKERS--
>> YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO DO
STICKERS IS APPARENTLY THE NEW
THING.
I GUESS TEACHERS ARE SUPPOSED TO
TAKE TIME OUT OF THEIR DAY AND
STICK BOOKS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO LOOK LIKE.
>> Larry: WASN'T COVERING UP
INFORMATION THAT GOT THEM IN
TROUBLE IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> NO MORE STICKERS.
>> Larry: WHAT I THINK YOU AND
YOUR SON HAVE DONE IS REALLY,
REALLY SPECIAL, AND WE WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING TO REMIND YOU OF THE
VIGILANCE AND WE ARE PRESENTING
YOU WITH THE "THE NIGHTLY SHOW"
STAY WOK AWARD.